weil insbesondere die neuen varianten
die jetzt kommen zu denen ich auch gerne
etwas sagen leute denn die green hat
bestimmte diese von einem ganz anderen
kaliber das ist auch eine ganz andere
hausnummer
wir haben noch mal ein ganz anderes
bedrohungspotenzial und müssen uns vor
augen führen das können wir nicht weg
kämpfen sondern das punkt bevor wir
genug menschen den deutschen auch in
deutschland haben können während wir
diese drei varianten in deutschland
haben ich halte es nicht für realistisch
wie es hier angedeutet worden ist von
frau carlitscheck und herrn lauterbach
dass wir den jetzigen lockdown oder gar
einen schärferen noch bis in den sommer
fortsetzen
ich sehe dass die stimmung in der
bevölkerung sich verändert hat es gibt
eine große ungeduld die sozialen und
wirtschaftlichen schäden wachsen
ich denke wird er gleich noch ein thema
sein an kita und schule
wir müssen also jetzt nach einem jahr
mittwoch ist das einjährige datum des
ersten patienten in deutschland der
erste näher kommen wir müssen auf eine
andere strategie wechseln